this is mark CTO of a large insurance
firm it's his job to ensure that all the
data that flows around the business is
secure so that he and his customers are
protected mark sleep soundly knowing
that MQ protects the business but recent
media headlines make him nervous mark
knows that his systems are secure but
what about the data inside those systems
you can see it now there's been a breach
you better get here it's bad things go
from bad to worse with Mark realizing
that thousands of customer sensitive
records have been hacked the company
will be fined their reputation will be
ruined and he will be fired but as data
is safe the company has just upgraded to
MQ advanced after years of successfully
growing with MQ mark had seen that there
was even more that he could do to
protect the business because with MQ
advanced he could protect data inside
his systems as well as data on the move
and with the encryption options
available market used to balance latency
and security requirements according to
the needs of the company Jarrod who's
been working on improving file transfer
within the company also likes the
upgrade as MQ advanced protects file
content data - meaning that he can focus
on other activities instead and as for
the recent orders it was relatively
painless as Mark could prove where data
resided and that it was well protected
with MQ advanced mark and sleeps soundly
knowing that his infrastructure and
customers are safe